and very exciting the 2017 david pakman
show calendar is now available for free
with memberships if you go to david
pakman.com slash calendar 17 you can
read about that I'll get more into the
details of that a little bit later today
remember that you can also support our
program if you ever shop on amazon.com
and I know some people in our audience
do and some people in our audience don't
and to everybody you know with total
peace and love whatever you're doing
keep doing it that's great but if you do
shop on amazon.com by visiting david
pakman.com slash amazon before shopping
the shopping you do will support the
work that we do very interestingly
somebody last week bought a novel by ben
winters you might remember a couple
weeks ago I interviewed been winters
about his novel underground Airlines and
mentioned that he has this other trilogy
called the last policeman trilogy and uh
one or two people in our audience
actually buying some of the last
policeman books which I haven't yet read
and I'm thinking about reading because i
liked underground airline so much so let
me know once you read it if you like it
and also a very good purchase made by
somebody who bought a Breville smart
grinder pro coffee bean grinder if
you've seen my making espresso videos
that we have on youtube you may have
noticed that i use a breville espresso
machine and i think they're absolutely
fantastic they are it's an Australian
company actually that a friend of mine
told me about and whoever bought the
Breville coffee grinder congratulations
you made a smart buying decision
remember david pakman.com slash amazon
stop there before shopping on amazon and
then the work you do the shopping you do
will support the work that we do